what is the rouge metric
for many nlp tasks we can use common
metrics like accuracy or f1 score but
what do you do when you want to measure
something like the quality of a summary
from a model like t5
in this video we'll take a look at a
widely used metric for text
summarization called root
there are actually several variants of
root but the basic idea behind all of
them is to assign a single numerical
score to a summary that tells us how
good it is compared to one or more
reference summaries
in this example we have a book review
that has been summarized by some model
if we compare the generated summary to
some reference human summaries we can
see that the model is actually pretty
good and only differs by a word or two
so how can we measure the quality of a
generator summary in an automatic way
the approach that rouge takes is to
compare the n-grams of the generated
summary to the n-grams of the references
an n-gram is just a fancy way of saying
a chunk of n words so let's start with
unigrams which correspond to the
individual words in a sentence
in this example you can see that six of
the words in the generated summary are
also found in one of the reference
summaries
and the rouge metric that compares
unigrams is called rouge one
now that we've found our matches one way
to assign a score to the summary is to
compute the recall of the unigrams
this means we just count the number of
matching words in the generated and
reference summaries and normalize the
count by dividing by the number of words
in the reference
in this example we found six matching
words and our reference has six words so
our unigram recall is perfect
this means that all of the words in the
reference summary have been produced in
the generated
one now perfect recall sounds great but
imagine if our generator summary had
been something like i really really
really really loved reading the hunger
games
this would also have perfect recall but
is arguably a worse summary since it is
verbose
to deal with these scenarios we can also
compute precision which in the rouge
context measures how much of the
generated summary was relevant
in practice both precision and recall
are usually computed and then the f1
score is reported
now we can change the granularity of the
comparison by comparing bi-grams instead
of unigrams
with bi-grams we chunk the sentence into
pairs of consecutive words and then
count how many pairs in the generated
summary are present in the reference one
this gives us rouge 2 precision and
recall which as we can see is lower than
the route 1 scores from earlier
now if the summaries are long the rouge
2 scores will generally be small because
there are fewer bigrams to match
and this is also true for abstract
summarization so both rouge one and
rouge two scores are usually reported
the last root variant we'll discuss is
root l
root l doesn't compare n grams but
instead treats each summary as a
sequence of words and then looks for the
longest common subsequence or lcs
a subsequence is a sequence that appears
in the same relative order but not
necessarily contiguous
so in this example i loved reading the
hunger games is the longest common
subsequence between the two summaries
and the main advantage of rouge l over
rouge one or rouge two is that it
doesn't depend on consecutive engram
matches and so it tends to capture
sentence structure much more accurately
now to compute root scores in the
datasets library is very simple
you just use the load metric function
provide your model summaries along with
the references and you're good to go
the output from the calculation contains
a lot of information the first thing we
can see is that the confidence intervals
of each root score are provided in the
low mid and high fields
this is really useful if you want to
know the spread of your route scores
when comparing two or more models
the second thing to notice is that we
have four types of root score we've
already seen rouge one root two and root
l so what is root l sum
well the simon rudel sum refers to the
fact that this metric is computed over a
whole summary while root l is computed
as the average over individual sentences